البدايه من واشنطن وتحديدا البيت الابيض
صفقه امريكيه ايرانيه لاطلاق سراح محتجزين
امريكيين مقابل سجناء ايرانيين والغاء
تجميد سته مليار دولار من عائدات النفط
الايراني على ماذا اتفقتم مع الجانب
الايراني في هذه الصفقه
نحن
يسعدنا ان نرى ان الامريكيين الخمسه قد
خرجوا من السجن وهم احدهم كان قد اقامه
الجبريه والان اتحدث عن اربع اشخاص اخرين
في هذه الوضعيه اليوم هذا امر جيد الا
يكون في السجن ولكنهم لم يخرجوا من ايران
بعد والمفاوضات تستمر مع الايرانيين
لمحاوله اخراجه من البلاد والعوده بهم الى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هنا حيث
ينتمون مع عائلاتهم لا نزالوا في مفاوضات
ناشطه مع الايرانيين وعندما يصلون الى
الولايات المتحده بسلامه وبامان واعتقد
اننا يمكننا ان نتحدث بشكل اكبر حول هذه
المفاوضات ماذا عن الاموال الايرانيه
المجمده هل هناك رقم اعتقد ان هناك بعض
الالتباس هنا بالنسبه الى موضوع فكره
الوصول الايرانيه الامر الذي نتحدث عنه هو
حسابات كانت اصلا من الاداره السابقه التي
سمحت عدد كبير من البلدان باستيراد
السلعه من ايران غير الخاضعه للعقوبات وان
توضع هذه الاموال في حسابات يمكن ايران ان
تسحب منها الاموال وقد قاموا بذلك في
الاداره السابقه تزال قيد الاستعمال نحن
نتحدث عن امكانيه استحداث اموال بحسابات
مشابهه اذا نفس الامر وان يتمكن
الايرانيون من الوصول اليها ما الذي ساهم
في تحقيق هذه الصفقه الان نحن
ركزنا دائما على عوده
الامريكيين الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بعد احتجازهم في ايران هذا
تركيزه الرئيس بايدن منذ اليوم الاول في
سنه الرئاسه واليوم نحن نتحدث عن خطوه
ايجابيه في الاتجاه الصحيح ولكنه نتيجه
اشهر واشهر من العمل المضني والدبلوماسيه
للوصول الى هذه المرحله ولكننا نتحدث عن
نقطه نقطه انطلاق وهناك الكثير من العمل
بعد متى يمكنكم القول بان هذه الصفقه قد
تمت
انه يمكنني ان اعود اليكم في المستقبل
القريب واقول انها قد تمت وان الامريكيين
الخمسه هم في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بسلامه مع عائلتهم اعتقد ان هذه العمليه
سوف تتطلب اسابيع ولكن ليس باستطاعتي ان
احدد عدد الاسابيع نحن نتعامل مع ايران
وبالتالي يتعينوا علينا ان نكون
براجماتيين في مقاربتنا وحذرين بالنسبه
الى التوقعات التي نقوم بها ولكن نامل
انها خطوه ايجابيه خطوه اولى جيده
لاستكمال العمليه ماذا عن الاطراف الراعيه
لهذه تحديدا الجانب القطري ماذا تعولون من
هذا الجانب
في الحقيقه ان دوله قطر كانت صديقه مميزا
بالنسبه الى مجالات متعدده ونحن نعبر عن
امتناننا اذا الدعم الذي حصلناه من حصلنا
عليه من دوله قطر بالنسبه الى هذه
المفاوضات على وجه الخصوص ولقطر صديق جيد
لنا وساعدنا بهذه العمليه هل سينعكس ما
حدث حتى الان لا اقول سبق او غيرها حتى
تتم كما ذكرت سيد كيربي على اهم الملفات
بين واشنطن ليس هذا على الاجنده الان ما
نتحدث مع ايران بشانه الان راج الامريكيين
من ايران وايصالهم الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نحن نركز حول كل الانشطه
المزعزعه لاستقرار لايران في المنطقه
وخصوصا دعم روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا
ودعم الشبكات الارهابيه في المنطقه
بالاضافه الى التهديدات
للسفن في البحار هناك نقاط كثيره ومتعدده
بنسبه الى السلوك الايراني وسوف نستمر
بالقيام بذلك